vous connaissez ce sentiment qu'on
éprouve quand on fait exactement ce
accord on est destiné celui qui vous
fait ressentir que tout en vous est en
parfaite harmonie avec l'univers
moi non plus mais vous savez il faut pas
perdre espoir
à ta maman parce que si tu le fais pas
elle va me détester encore plus et bien
je me souviens que tu avais dit que
devenir avocat aurait détruit ton âme en
effet je gère une mission et cette
mission en ce moment c'est de faire
entrer sortir une journaliste de
paldonia
non si juste une fois
je suis pas intéressé même pas pour
20000 dollars
[Musique]
du corps nous a sauvé c'est un héros
suis avec le président d'un pays en
plein coup d'État c'est le scoop d'une
vie pour moi faut être vivante pour
avoir le scoop de votre vie on aurait
jamais dû venir partant on peut pas
l'abandonner
[Musique]
le voilà allez pour pas
le moment de faire du coaching
franchement
[Musique]
dites-moi que vous avez filmé ça